John you can do this you just go and you  don't look back my whole life I prepared  my son to lead humanity in the fight  against the machines there was one thing  I could never prepare him for the  machines tried to rig the game sent a  terminator back to the time before the  war to kill my mother I'll go back let  me save her  a lease you know one we've been prepping  for you to write over a decade we the  Terminator it is nice to meet you  I've been trying to teach him to blend  in I know it needs work how can you be  here  what have they done to my son  survival was what you taught me  get out  not machine  not man  whatever they did to Sharmini rehearsal  everything's changed we are humanity's  last hope  load up  I've been waiting for you  gotta get him off me I'll be back what  you  you